like fallout shelter we wanted an
experience that we were not finding
anywhere else here it is blades at its
heart is a pure Elder Scrolls game a
massive first-person RPG with console
quality graphics but with a uniquely
mobile experience believe me when I say
you have to see this running on an
iPhone 10 this gigantic screen does not
do it justice you can tap to move or use
dual sticks
[Music]
combat is all-new and it follows your
specific movements and timings harkening
back to the first Elder Scrolls arena
this game features both handcrafted and
procedurally generated dungeons
and it's not just melee you have a range
of abilities and spells you can use
and of course you can create your own
character and be who you want to be
improving them levelling up picking new
abilities
[Music]
and the entire game can be played in
portrait mode
that one was incredibly important to us
that you could play up however you
wanted you never know when you'll need a
free hand
to hold your coffee what are you
degenerates
[Music]
and it's not just dungeons it's
incredible
outdoor areas yes running on a phone
it really looks and plays incredible
what place has several modes of play
first the abyss a robe like experience
where you can see how far you can go in
an endless dungeon in the arena where
you will do battle one-on-one against
other players and the main mode the town
this is the hub for your story and
quests you are a member of the blades
the Empire's top agents forced in exile
you return home to find your town
destroyed and need to rebuild it
yes blades also features a town building
mode you'll decide what your town looks
like and be able to upgrade and decorate
all of the individual elements in it as
your town levels up you unlock new NPCs
quests and more you can even visit your
friends towns
[Music]
this
[Applause]
this is an Elder Scrolls game that you
can play however and wherever you want
and we are going to bring blades to
every device and system we can phones
PCs consoles also virtual reality on
mobile all the way up to high end VR on
PCs and what's really cool is all of
those connect to each other so one of my
dreams as well go back to that portrait
mode you like to call meeting mode
because if you're in a meeting on you're
playing a game in portrait mode no one
knows you're playing a game and so with
blades you could be in a meeting playing
blades against someone at home in VR
blades is coming this fall for free
and you can pre-order it tonight on both
the Apple App Store and the Google Play
Store also this week go to play blades
comm and register for early access if
you're here at e3 blades is going to be
playable on our booth so please come by
and check it out you really need to see
it running on the phone we'd love to see
you please come by
[Applause]
[Music]